Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Paula Motter
Gracias. Buenas tardes, ¿cómo están?
Audiencia: ¡Bien!
Bueno, el tema que les traigo
es a lo mejor un poquito complicado,
pero es una realidad a la cual
nos tenemos que enfrentar
cuando estamos estudiando
una carrera o un posgrado.
¿Qué sientes cuando
escuchas la palabra 'tesis'?
¿Qué pasa por tu mente?
¿Por qué sientes o piensas eso?
En México, el 96 % de las universidades
contienen materias
de corte de investigación
que tienen como propósito, precisamente,
realizar protocolos de tesis.
Y el 2 % de estas universidades
la utiliza como única alternativa
para que te puedas titular.
Cierto es que la gran mayoría
de las universidades hoy en día
te ofrecen alternativas
para poderte titular.
Y si las consigues, no está mal.
Si consigues el promedio,
te puedes titular por promedio
y estás en todo tu derecho.
Si quieres hacer un estudio de posgrado,
si quieres, a lo mejor,
realizarlo con alguna investigación
de acuerdo a tus prácticas,
está bien.
A continuación te presento
mi vivencia, precisamente,
como estudiante y como docente.
Vengo de una familia de clase baja.
Tuve formación de casa tradicional,
educación en escuelas públicas
y aprendizaje en el barrio,
ese aprendizaje que me hizo
ganarme a mis mejores amigos.
En mi etapa de bachillerato,
lo más cercano a lo que era investigar
--seguramente Uds. lo vivieron también--
era copiar información de un libro,
de una biografía o de una planilla,
de las que conseguíamos
y se siguen consiguiendo en la esquina,
en una papelería.
Mis visitas a la biblioteca
no eran muy frecuentes,
a menos que fuera
por indicación de un maestro.
Dos momentos marcaron
esta etapa de mi vida.
La primera, el no haber ingresado
a la Facultad de Contaduría,
y la segunda, una situación económica
familiar un poquito delicada.
Afortunadamente, con el apoyo
de mis padres, de mis hermanas
y mi trabajo como taxista,
pude inscribirme en una institución
nueva y particular en el Puerto.
Escogí la carrera de
Informática Administrativa.
A principios de los 90,
una carrera que tenía una proyección
de poder conseguir trabajo
de una manera muy fácil, muy rápida,
debido a que los equipos de cómputo
se estaban incorporando a las empresas.
Quién iba a decirlo: mi giro laboral
se enfocaba hacia la parte educativa.
Cuando estudias en
una carrera de corte práctico
y te encuentras con algunas
asignaturas de corte teórico,
no encuentras un porqué
o un para qué de esas materias.
Mi alma mater, como
muchas otras universidades,
manejaba alguna de ellas,
como por ejemplo: Seminario de Tesis.
Sí les puedo compartir que a todos
los del grupo nos costaba mucho trabajo
el manejo de los contenidos
de investigación.
Trasladar lo teórico a nuestros proyectos
de investigación era bastante complicado.
Sin embargo, el asesor nos decía
que todo iba de acuerdo a lo planeado.
La investigación ya no era
solo copiar información.
Teníamos que seguir un proceso,
y ese proceso tenía que estar fundamentado
en especialistas de acuerdo a tu área.
En el octavo semestre,
a tres meses de concluir mi carrera,
mi asesor dejó
de laborar en la universidad
y todos los trabajos le fueron
asignados a un nuevo maestro.
La primera sesión jamás se olvida.
El nuevo asesor revisaba
detenidamente mi avance,
y cada una de las hojas
venía con correcciones,
modificaciones y observaciones.
En otras palabras,
en tres meses tuve que realizar
el trabajo de dos semestres.
Dos asesores con una forma de interpretar
una metodología de investigación
te cambian todo el panorama.
Mi idea de defender mi tesis,
mi proyecto, ante un jurado,
perdió valor.
Y lo único que me interesaba
era la calificación y concluir mi carrera.
Más o menos por ese tiempo,
ya me encontraba laborando
como docente de computación
en el nivel secundario y bachillerato en
una institución hermana de la universidad.
Y eso me promovió a ganarme el 50 %
de mis primeros estudios de posgrado.
No podía dejar pasar esa oportunidad.
Contaba yo con apenas 22 años y, para mí,
era un logro que había alcanzado.
Cuando no eres rico...
[Audio interrumpido]
... y además no eres muy guapo,
tienes que aprovechar las oportunidades
porque el tiempo
es un recurso no renovable
y difícilmente pueden
volver a presentarse.
Sí les puedo compartir que en
dos años de Maestría en Educación
leí lo que en mi vida
académica había leído.
En mi carrera de corte práctico,
sí hubo noches de desvelo,
pero aquí, por el manejo
de la información,
fueron semanas de escasos
recursos de descanso.
Pero, como siempre,
tuve a alguien que me apoyaba.
Mi madre, recuerdo que me dijo:
"Hijo,
nosotros te apoyamos.
Chíngale, que ya te falta poco".
Una vez egresado de la maestría,
mi universidad me dio la oportunidad
de estar dentro de su plantilla docente.
Me reencontraría con un viejo conocido,
de quien fui becario como estudiante,
y hasta el día de hoy seguimos manteniendo
una muy bonita relación de amistad.
El ingeniero y yo
hemos convivido en diferentes etapas
y diferentes instituciones educativas,
y yo aprendí mucho de él
Lo considero mi 'sensei'.
Sin embargo, recuerdo que en
una de las primeras reuniones me dijo:
"Tu principal defecto como docente
es que te pones en el lugar
de tus estudiantes".
Y yo le contesté: "Fíjese que,
para mí, esa es mi mayor fortaleza".
Sin embargo, cada quien ve
la esfera desde diferentes ángulos.
Respeto su opinión.
Me incomodó muchísimo su comentario
y sentí como un golpe
al hígado muy, muy fuerte.
Estar como asesor
de materias de investigación,
tanto en los niveles
de licenciatura como en posgrados,
me ha dejado muy bonitas experiencias
y momentos bastante complicados.
A la gran mayoría de los alumnos
lo único que les interesa
es la calificación.
No les interesa el proceso de investigar.
"El seis es suficiente
y lo demás es vanidad"
es un mensaje que retumba en mis oídos,
y hiere mi amor propio a la docencia.
No digo que todos, pero
la gran mayoría de los estudiantes
no sabemos investigar.
Y no son únicos responsables.
Durante años hay un personaje
que ha estado alimentado ese proceder
y esa forma de pensar y de actuar:
los docentes.
En los niveles anteriores
y en la misma carrera,
los docentes le damos un trato
muy bajo a lo que es investigación.
Decimos que es investigación
definir un término o un concepto.
Encargamos un trabajo
sin estructura, sin fundamento,
sin referencias de información
y lo damos por bueno.
Y cuando los estudiantes
se enfrentan, en estas materias,
a un protocolo de investigación,
simple y sencillamente están navegando
en un mapa sin destino.
Pero...
¿de qué nos quejamos cuando
egresamos de una universidad?
De que no tenemos trabajo,
de que no hay oportunidades.
Las oportunidades hay que buscarlas.
Si no es en Veracruz,
a nivel nacional o internacional.
Pero sobre todo, chavos,
gente, hay que ganarlas.
¿Qué pensarías si yo te dijera
que tu proyecto de investigación
te puede catapultar a conseguir un puesto
en una empresa nacional o internacional,
o te puede promover para que consigas
una beca en un estudio de posgrado
o, simple y sencillamente,
puedes abrir tu propio negocio
como emprendedor?
Ustedes dirán: "¿Qué debo hacer?".
De entrada, no esperar a que otra gente
haga lo que te compete a ti.
Para poder lograr lo que nunca has tenido,
tendrás que hacer lo que nunca has hecho.
Es por ello
que si tú valoras estas materias,
si estás estudiando en
una universidad o un posgrado
y valoras estas materias,
tu tesis pasa de ser un vehículo
para calificación de unas materias
a ser un transporte de oportunidad.
A nivel nacional está
el Instituto del Emprendedor.
El mes pasado, curiosamente, fue la semana
del emprendedor a nivel nacional.
Rompe fronteras,
busca alternativas en otros países.
Canadá y Australia son
dos de los principales países
que apoyan a México.
Hay convenios.
Canadá en febrero,
prácticamente todo febrero,
les abre la oportunidad a chavos,
preferentemente titulados,
para que puedan trabajar
allá y quedarse allá.
Pueden checar Uds. en su embajada,
o también pueden checar en la Secretaría
de Relaciones Exteriores de nuestro país.
Australia, por su parte, tiene
dos programas que nos pueden apoyar.
Uno laboral, en donde prácticamente
está abierta la oportunidad todo el año;
y otro para proyectos innovadores
que generalmente se apertura
entre agosto y septiembre.
Para finalizar, te comento
que tú eres el principal
promotor de tu trabajo.
No le eches la culpa a nadie.
Aprende del maestro, con el maestro,
sin el maestro y a pesar del maestro.
Sé consciente del entorno en donde estás,
sé consciente de que este entorno
que se te presenta hoy en día
te da la posibilidad y
las oportunidades de poder conseguir
escenarios completamente distintos
a los de otras generaciones.
Estás precisamente en un espacio
en donde los recursos,
las formas y los medios físicos
y virtuales te dan esa posibilidad.
Te pido por favor que rompas fronteras.
No pidas oportunidades. Créalas.
Cree por favor en el potencial que tienes.
Sé consciente,
sé agente de cambio,
sé exitoso,
sé feliz con lo que tienes.
Pero ve en busca de tu futuro
y de lo que quieres.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)